i'm curious do you see zara differently
from an actor perspective versus a
viewer perspective
as you're actually watching the finished
product she
has like such an arc where i think it's
intended for the audience to like
not agree with what she does then to be
able to render again and then go the
other way
so what is that push-pull like for you
it's
it's hard because you can't ever judge
your own character you know you have to
kind of be on their side
but she has made choices that like
sometimes i'm just
like okay why why is this happening
but what i do have control over as the
actor is
is the back story is this stuff that
sort of justifies
the characters choices and so for me the
big thing was that like
she never really wanted to come on this
train in the first place and now that
she's here
she's just like trying to find some
sense of purpose
and i think this baby is is what she's
hoping is going to give her
like a reason to live really and so
that's something that i could see
and i think people can relate to that of
just like feeling like there's no reason
to like why am i part of this thing this
thing is a mess
and and she evolves she continues to
sort of like
um do what she needs to do to keep
surviving
to like not be swallowed up by the
intensity of the train
and so yeah i tried to just lean into
the moral gray of it all because i
i do like that but it's it's a tricky
balancing act as an actor because
you even if your character is not
likable and also i'm often
advocating in a way to see more
unlikable women because
because i think there's just too much of
like oh if when we see like female
representation should always be like
hospitable and polite and
agreeable like it's okay to see like
nasty girls too and so um but then it's
hard because then at the same time you
have to deal with like yeah there's
people who
definitely don't like zara and don't
like what she's up to
um but that's okay it's uh what's nice
about a tv show is that things can go
all over the place there's like
sitting after so much you got the
foundation there to justify her
decisions though which i think uh it
definitely
makes it work quite well in season one
i'm not sure what you can tease about
season two but you know you bring up
zara's baby
being a source of motivation for her
survival
in season two but will we get to see
maybe the impact that her seeing the
tail
stick together and rise up and see this
revolution
through affect how she behaves in season
two as well
yeah you start to see that i think right
at the end of season one she kind of
joins
she helps with the revolution um
and so but again she like toes the line
all the time
so i feel like she cares less
in a way about the grander politics than
she does about
andre i always felt like like she was
searching for love like that was like
the only thing left that she believed in
and i feel like once you've lost
everybody in your life like all your
family members all your
the world has frozen over everything
you've ever really loved is gone you're
just
stuck on this thing like it's
it starts to feel like you know just
existential for her
and um so
she continues on like the trajectory
she's on in a lot of ways
but i feel like she's still
finding her her way in this world and
maybe that's not a bad thing like i can
certainly relate to not quite fitting in
anywhere and and and sometimes
floundering in that in that kind of
misfit place